The question is, "Does your WHY change in
time?"
The answer is, no it does not.
We all only have one WHY.
Our WHY is fully formed, probably in our late
teens, something like that.
And the rest of our lives offer us opportunities
to live in balance with that WHY, or not.
Now, the language can evolve for sure, but
the basic idea, the basic sentiment of what
the WHY is, is permanent.
It is basically an origin story.
That's what a WHY is.
A WHY is a sum total of who we are based on
how we were raised, the experiences we had
as kids.
Just like the WHY for an organization is also
basically an origin story.
It's where the organization comes from.
It's based on the problem that the founders
were trying to solve or the opportunity they
were trying to grasp, whatever it is.
So, your WHY is fixed.
Your WHY is permanent.
The language can evolve but you are who you
are.
We are who we all are.